quand vous allez voir 10 à 99 ce sont
des adultes
quand vous allez voir trois à neuf ce
sont des enfants franciliens voient
leurs ventes partir faites très
attention donné le nombre d'enfants et
le nombre d'adultes un briefing rapide
des dernières consignes de raphaël david
reese est le dispatcheur et les guides
touristiques sont sur le pied de guerre
prêt à accueillir les premiers passagers
le dispatcheur en quelque sorte sonné le
poumon un petit peu de toutes les
excursions très vendues par les bateaux
de croisière et sur le site on est entre
guillemets le chef d'orchestre
je dors caisse avec l'interface entre le
lescure sioniste est à dire le storex
quitte à bord avec également les guides
et les chauffeurs de bus il faut
toujours mettre notre pays en avant se
dire la martinique parler dans la
lentille nick ce qu'on fait ici
comment vivent les gens sur l'île ils
veulent beaucoup savoir sur tout ce qui
est croyant soumis et comment ça se
passe dans le pays surtout parlé des
mystères des passagers qui sont partis
de floride pour une croisière de douze
jours et qui pour certains viennent pour
la première fois en martinique et soit
c'est curieux de découvrir l'île on veut
rencontrer les gens foot et la
nourriture je vais découvrir la culture
tellement beau ici et ça faisait un
moment qu'on voulait venir
j'ai hâte de découvrir l'île je suis
enthousiaste je viens d caroline du nord
ici c'est génial cette escale du disney
fantasy marge la fin de la saison de la
croisière et le bilan est plutôt positif
on aura dépassé dans cette saison les
six cent mille six cent mille passagers
settings exemple une saison
exceptionnelle pour les raisons que vous
savez les ouragans et en mai marillac
complète des goûts télé
quelques navires ici à m'enseigner la
saison prochaine en principe nous
devrions avoir environ 200 escale ce qui
nous ramène à la saison précédente
avant il omet et maria pour les
exposants cette dernière escale tardive
est un plus la cerise sur le gâteau ta
femme tes pincement au coeur parce que
ça veut dire
peut-être pas d'activité paravent
la saison prochaine qui doit commencer
en octobre donc c'est vrai que c'est un
petit manque à gagner mais on a eu quand
même une belle saison donc c'est pas fun
qui n'est pas habitué à voir des bateaux
mois juillet donc voilà c'est un plus on
apprend sa journée bonus
prochaine escale du disney fantasy 5,8